[Music]
how are our homes and businesses
contributing to climate change in
teambridge
and what positive steps can we take to
reduce our impact
what will climate change mean for team
bridge and why should we take action
the emissions we produce here in team
bridge contribute to global
accumulations of greenhouse gases which
in turn warms our climate
so far we have seen an average global
temperature increase of 1.2 degrees
celsius since the industrial revolution
as a consequence of our warming climate
we can expect hotter and drier summers
wetter and milder winters and increasing
sea levels on our shores in team bridge
the effects of climate change in teen
bridge will affect the health and
resilience of our communities and
increase pressure on our natural
environment
left unchecked our homes will be more
susceptible to overheating
our communities more vulnerable to
flooding and our countryside and
wildlife prone to weather extremes
what are the key sources of emissions in
teambridge
heating and powering our homes and
businesses accounts for 20
and 15 percent of emissions respectively
in teambridge
transport makes up 47 of our carbon
footprint with agriculture making a
further 12 contribution
the foods and products we buy and the
waste we produce also plays a
significant role in our carbon footprint
to avoid the worst effects of climate
change we as residents businesses
visitors to the district and public
sectors across devon need to take action
only with immediate action can we limit
accumulations of greenhouse gases in our
atmosphere and avoid the worst effects
of climate change
team bridge has already decarbonized by
26 since 2005
and so we aren't starting from scratch
however
we still need to increase our efforts
the steps we take to reduce our impact
will depend on the circumstances of each
individual and business
each and every step we take be it small
or large will add up and make a
difference
to start your net zero journey
measure your carbon footprint and have a
look at our top tips for reducing it see
our guidance on the devon climate
emergency website to see how your
business school and community group can
get involved get in touch with your
local community climate action group and
your town or parish council to engage in
initiatives in your area and finally
subscribe to the devon climate emergency
newsletter for the latest on the devon
carbon plan for a net zero
[Music]